depuis samedi soir impossible de faire
ses courses passé 18 heures avec
l'avancement du couvre feu sur
l'ensemble du territoire les commerçants
sont contraints de s'adapter
l'objectif est maintenant simple restez
ouvert le plus longtemps possible
il a fallu changer les horaires
d'ouverture nous avons normalement une
amplitude de 10 heures à 20 heures le
samedi et au nouveau à 11 heures la
semaine est donc là on a avancé notre
ouverture à 9 heures et nous fermons à
18 heures désormais les boutiques compte
sur l'heure du déjeuner pour rattraper
le manque à gagner en soirée un
changement forcé qui ne compensera pas
les baisses de fréquentation les
boutiques
et voit surtout le manque de chiffre
d'affaires puisque le créneau horaire 18
20 heures est un créneau horaire qui
effectivement fort donc entre 20 et 40%
de la journée donc elle voit avant tout
la perte de chiffre d'affaires mais il
faut faire seulement deux heures de
décalage qui rendent pourtant difficile
les sorties en magasin entre le travail
les activités et la famille pas le choix
il faut changer ses habitudes
globalement oui ça va sûrement ça va
être plus dur c'est sûr quand je dirais
dans la semaine quand on travaille ça va
pas changer grand chose mais
effectivement pour faire ses courses
oui c'est un peu plus tendue quoi ça
nous oblige à légèrement avancer nos
habitudes en hiver pour connaître c'est
pas trop contraignant
c'est juste une question d'organisation
alors que les soldes commencent mercredi
prochain les commerçants craignent que
le couvre-feu à 18 heures entraîne une
nouvelle fois une baisse de
fréquentation dans les magasins